how did The Rock uh come about did you
create the Rock or did Vince come up
with that idea what what happened it was
a combination of both and it just it
kind of uh evolved and where did he find
you the the Vince under a rock
and that was it I was uh down at
University of Miami playing football I
graduated from there and then after that
and because I grew up in the business
actually and um and you weren't violent
guy as a youth I read your uh sort of
like a bio on you right you you rock did
some bad things The Rock was bad right
you would like choke guys and get into
fights with guys all the time right each
incident was worse than the next and
what straightened you out probably just
uh trying to mature a little bit Yeah I
gotta try that anger management classes
yeah did you ever have to go to anger
management either too you did yeah and
so you were a football player and all
that and then you came up through the
ranks right and uh even wrestling was in
your family yeah exactly my grandfather
worked for Vince's old man in the 70s
right and my dad worked for Vince in the
80s wow so everyone was a wrestler wow
didn't your dad like once someone made
your grandfather someone made fun of a
meeting with his hands and then your
grandfather just took him and threw him
out a window
when my dad is Rocky Johnson okay and my
grandfather was Peter and yeah that that
that's a true story yeah it was in a in
a hotel he threw him through the uh
Lobby window wow